for more we are joined now in our
Washington Newsroom by CBS News
Congressional correspondent Scott
McFarland good morning Scott what was it
about vote number 15 I should say they
got McCarthy over the hump yeah 15th
round knockout what happened was he
figured out what to do with that group
that small group of members of his
conference who said they would never
ever vote for Kevin McCarthy they didn't
but they voted present which changed the
math and really cleared the way from
McCarthy to get by with a smaller number
they got themselves out of the way
earlier in the evening he had made some
concessions to give some of this faction
of dissenters inside his conference
better positions on better committees
they'll have their fingerprints on every
piece of legislation that goes through
the U.S house with a good committee
position but the acrimony you saw and
the acrimony we heard that built could
Define the next two years years of this
U.S House of Representatives
I'm going to call it a 15th round TKO
not a KO necessarily but um talk about
some of the challenges that McCarthy now
faces I think he was asked last night if
he thinks he's going to serve his full
two years of speaker he said a thousand
percent I will but he does face those
challenges Jeff this faction that broke
away and caused him such trouble on
what's usually the simplest vote of the
U.S Congress could surface again on
tougher more contentious pieces of
legislation but really any small group
of Republicans could do so because the
margins are so slim he could only lose
four or five votes on anything and there
are much more difficult things to come
like keeping the government open
government spending military issues or
more Arcane pieces of federal policy
Scott when you're talking about that I'm
thinking of two things sort of along the
lines of how much power did he give to
this holdout group in in making some of
these concessions but also how much
power does this potentially give to
Democrats in seeing so much unrest in
the Republican Party
one senior house Democrat Richie Neal
who last year chaired the house Ways and
Means Committee told me last night what
happens when the debt ceiling needs to
be raised later this year
seemingly some Coalition of Republicans
and Democrats will be needed because the
Republicans seem unable to gather their
own votes for such a contentious thing
and you'll recall from 2011. if you
nearly breach the debt ceiling if you
don't raise the debt ceiling in a timely
fashion you can cause a huge Tremor in
the U.S economy hitting the stock market
hitting jobs hitting people's wallets
yeah there's one more piece of business
that freshman Senator Republican
freshman Senator George Santos what does
his future hold
the congressman Santos he is now a
congressman he's been sworn in we spent
this week pursuing him for answers to
questions about his background he still
refuses to answer
okay Scott McFarland from D.C after uh
an early morning after a long night
Scott we appreciate all of your great
work this week thanks so much